[Music]  baby backs I wish you to use my powers  will become yours wait for you okay  [Music]  this is crazy right what are your  superpowers simmer for hours dude I  don't even know how to pee in this thing  electricity manipulation  hyperspeed I'd like to purchase some of  your finest beer please is Kathy Sparkle  fingers no it's not it's not me that's  not my name chosen one like a bad guy  you really did the opposite of what a  superhero supposed to do you're him  you're the hero you're welcome for not  getting robbed  I won't do you basically 15  [Music]  yeah he will let the computer to bus and  almost kill these people and then I  caught it  you need tall buildings in a single  bound  [Music]